Et pourquoi pas un château ?
Ah oui ! C’est
quand même notre mariage.
Pourquoi pas un groupe ?
Et pourquoi pas des knacki ?
Ben oui, pourquoi pas des knakci ?
Putain, je m’occupe du château,
du DJ, de la calèche
Toi, tu devais juste gérer la bouffe
et tu prends des knacki ?
Mais tu m’avais dit oui.
Mais je pensais que
c’était une blague !
Mais tout le monde aime bien
les knacki, non ?
Attendez, vous allez où là ?
Non, mais moi je suis végan,
alors je vais…
Moi, je ne mange pas de porc.
Désolée.
Revenez au moins pour le gâteau !
Non chérie,
le gâteau il est fait en knacki aussi.
Mais tu fais chier !
Crac crac ?
Et vous les gourmands,
votre journée vous la commencez comment ?
Cracotte.
Crac crac.
Crac crac. J’ai compris le message.
J’aimerais bien que tu
croques dans ma biscotte.
Bah là, c’est ma
biscotte qui va être croquée là,
si tu vois ce que je veux dire.
Tu m’étales ta confiture.
D’ailleurs,
vous avez une alarme vous ?
Oui, on a fait installer Verisure.
Et la caméra,
c’est pour ?
Verisure.
Ils la déclenchent si quelqu’un essaie de
nous cambrioler.
Rendez-vous sur verisure.fr
D’ailleurs, vous avez
une alarme vous ?
Oui, on a fait installer Verisure.
Et la caméra,
c’est pour ?
Bah, c’est ce qu’elle vient de dire.
Ah non, on n’a pas parlé de caméra.
Elle est pour quoi, là ?
C’est l’alarme globalement.
Vous allez où en vacances ?
Mais on est filmés depuis le début,
en fait. C’est ça ?
C’est une caméra cachée.
–Très très cons.
–Oui.
Ah, tous les jours cette fichue poussière.
Utiliser un chiffon,
la galère.
C’est pourquoi je suis passé à Swiffer.
Utiliser un chiffon,
la galère.
C’est quoi ton problème là ?
Non, mais c’est le chiffon.
La galère.
Tu prends, tu lèves
t’essuies, et tu reposes.
Ah putain ! Pas besoin de Swiffer
du tout en fait.
Non, il faut juste être moins con.
🎵 C’est bien sec,
pas de stress 🎵
🎵 like a bosch 🎵
🎵 Ma facture est en baisse 🎵
Bosch.
Chérie, ça va ?
Qu’est-ce qui se passe ?
Bah pas ouf le bosch.
Ça ne marche pas.
Non, il est tout neuf.
Il marche très bien.
Regarde.
Tu vois ?
Il faut qu’on appelle le service
après-vente.
Tu ne touches plus aux assiettes,
d’accord ?
On fait comme ça ?
Encore une petite s’il te plaît.
–Non.
–Tu ne peux pas le faire avec moi ?
C’est hyper drôle.
Fais comme tu veux,
parce que je divorce,
en fait.
Je suis en train de me dire comme tu veux.
Ça, c’est mon papa.
Un jour, il m’a dit que lui aussi
il a une arme secrète :
ses nouvelles chaussures U-Power.
Mais c’est quoi ce bordel ?
C’est mon gamin
il a pris ma chaussure pour l’école.
Vous vous foutez de
ma gueule ou quoi ?
Non non, c’est pour un exposé.
Mais qui fait des exposés
sur des chaussures de chantier,
nom de Dieu ?
Je sais. J’en ai marre de ce gamin.
Il m’énerve.
–Vous êtes viré.
–Je comprends.
Faites le premier pas vers la
confidentialité en ligne,
obtenez la meilleureoffre NordVPN.
Vous pouvez utiliser NordVPN
pour protéger vos données
mais aussi pour changer votre localisation,
pour accéder à
d’autres contenus sur Netflix,
ou accéder à des événements sportifs sur
la formule un, par exemple.
Mais attends,
Cyprien.
C’est pas du tout
une parodie de pub là ?
Non. Ça, c’est une vraie pub.
Comme dans la vraie vie,
il y a de vraies pubs parfois.
Ah, tu es fort.
Ouais, je sais.
Vous pouvez cliquer sur le lien
dans la description
pour avoir une grosse
réduc et un petit cadeau.
C’est satisfait ou remboursé
pendant trois jours.
Profitez-en.
Très fort.
Dites non à jeter.
Dites oui à réparer.
Dites oui à Loctite.
C’est carrément écologique de
réparer, en fait.
C’est écologique ?
Tu viens de commander un tube de colle.
Téma le carton !
Tu penses un peu au transport,
aux camions,
tout ce que tu as utilisé
pour un tube de colle
que tu aurais pu acheter en bas de la rue ?
Optique2000, bonjour !
Ma mère a besoin de lunettes,
mais elle ne peut plus se déplacer.
Pas de problèmes.
C’est nous qui nous déplaçons chez elle.
Bon, je vous laisse.
Je vais la voir.
🎵 Optique2000 🎵
Je vous laisse,
je vais la voir.
Allo ?
Vous n’avez pas l’adresse.
Je ne vous ai pas donné l’adresse.
Putain, mais elle s’en bas les couilles
de ma mère ou… ?
Tout le monde me connait,
et m’adore.
On ne va pas y passer la nuit !
Bon, je ne vois pas.
Si !
Justin Bridou, le vrai goût du partage.
Donc tout le monde me connaît ?
–Ouais.
–Et m’adore ?
Ouais, allez, vas-y.
On ne va pas y passer la nuit.
Non, je ne vois pas.
Qui a écrit cette merde ?
C’est moi.
Donc, tu as juste écrit un truc
que tu avais sous les yeux,
en fait ?
Qu’est-ce que t’es pas drôle !
Quand on joue à ce jeu,
tu imagines quelque chose
d’autre pour s’amuser.
Tu n’écris pas un truc
qu’il y a devant toi.
Propose quelque chose d’autre.
Une assiette ?
Putain, mais il est nul !
Stop, stop. Ciao !
Toi tu dirais combien ?
220 000 ?
Combien ?
C’est moins ?
Non, c’est combien pour
mon bien.fr Jean-Bat !
Jean-Bat.
Je peux t’appeler Jean-Bat,
Jean-Bat ?
230 000 alors.
Combien ?
Mais il est rentré par où ?
Vous êtes qui, monsieur ?
Je suis ton pote Jean-Bat.
Je peux t’appeler Jean-Bat ?
Mais c’est une propriété
privée ici, monsieur.
Oui, on va appeler la police.
Non, pas encore la police !
Ah oui, c’est l’asile d’à côté.
J’avais oublié.
Oui, 110 000, 100 000 ?
–Allez, on se barre.
–Oui oui, comme ça on s’en va.
Qu’est-ce que tu fais ?
Bah, je…
Bah, je quoi ?
Tu as entendu parler du
plastique qui pollue les océans ?
Ça te fait rire ?
Avec soda stream,
l’eau du robinet devient pétillante.
Tu fais quoi ?
Bah, je…
Bah, je quoi ?
Tu as entendu parler du plastique
qui pollue les océans ?
Et ça te fait rire ?
Tu ne veux plus de plastique ?
Très bien.
On va t’enlever toutes tes poupées alors.
Tes baskets sont en plastique aussi.
On va te trouver des baskets en carton.
Ça va faire fureur à l’école.
–Vous plaisantez ?
–Ça te fait rire ?
Allez, va dans ta chambre là.
Je ne voulais pas d’enfant,
moi.
C’est un accident.
Donc la forêt,
tu vois un rayon de lumière
taper dans les feuillages.
Tension au max.
Et là, il débarque sorti de nulle part.
Magnifique !
Mais le truc de dingue !
Un sanglier,
mon frère.
Mais tu vis des trucs de ouf à la
chasse, toi !
Et là il débarque,
magnifique !
Mais le truc de dingue.
Un sanglier,
mon frère.
Tu l’as buté,
du coup ?
Ouais, mais là je
te parlais de la forêt,
de la lumière.
Non non, la forêt,
la lumière,
ça s’appelle se balader en forêt.
Quand tu te balades en forêt,
tu peux croiser un sanglier sans le buter.
Tu l’as buté ?
Moi j’aime bien buter
les animaux avec un fusil.
Quand il passe, paf,
je shoot.
Ouais, ne fais plus ça.
Ne fais plus ça.
Ça fait peur à tout le
monde quand tu en parles, OK ?
Et toi Seb, tu ferais quoi toi frérot
avec 130millions ?
Moi, je...
Je partagerais avec vous.
C’est quoi ça ?
C’est toi qui as gagné ?
Ouais.
On a tous gagné.
Et toi frérot,
tu ferais quoi avec 130millions
d’euros ?
Moi je...
Je partagerais avec vous.
C’est toi qui as gagné ?
On a tous gagné.
Non ! Tu bouges pas !
On a tous gagné !
Mais ta gueule toi, file la thune.